hey guys I'm Ryan right people go
I'm salamander Sally and élisa élisa be
cray they both have their own channel
say that up front salamander Sally
Alyssa be crazy subscribe to both please
just take time out to do it right now
yet anyway uh there's this trailer out
for this movie this is awesome I'm just
sitting right here like a [ __ ] pimp a
p IM p hell yeah dog yeah yeah yeah
comment below and tell me how awesome I
am
thanks thank you this trailer this one
guy has been like telling me to watch it
over and over again the course don't
remember his [ __ ] name right now but
oh wow it is like so hot in here and I
think it's because I'm sitting in
between YouTube right now it is like
really I'm starting to sweat is it a
physical chemical reaction to being
around a girl because this is like track
10 this is the most intimacy I've ever
received in my entire life why is my
pulse racing so fast yeah you're nervous
person are you pregnant
I haven't had my period you know what
it's rated R for disturbing bloody
violence in language oh wait what what
is the name of it what it's called
afflicted oh no no I think it's a horror
movie
is there anyone famous in it I don't
know alright that's right now look girls
I'm telling you I don't know anything
about this okay God having two
girlfriends is so tough I don't know how
Charlie Sheen did it because he's not
human
until the Tigers blood yeah exactly
uh Charlie Sheen jokes you're never
getting old Oh woody here we go okay
it's fine don't worry
good I trust you nope CBS films tomorrow
the Jewish guy in an Asian guy tired my
co-host online at the town blog it's
gonna be happening
I don't like this this is pretty cool
sorry Mike I don't want to stop the
check
you're freaking me out right now just
stop Dan he's like a superhuman now I
need to see the hospital there's nothing
they can do home right let's just go
home he's morphing into something yeah I
don't know I have no idea what's going
on with there
but what he did should be impossible
damn I made an Asian guy the lead how
cool is that
do you think this happened I don't know
I need to find Audrey starts with her
okay I feel fine
we're about to bust in on Derek in the
garage as Victor
: anyway
wake up Oh like this is showing too much
I really want to see it though cuz I
have no idea what the hell's like oh I'm
really intrigued oh look at those
reviews don't forget that off the screen
that dreams yeah dude let's always you
do yeah yeah yeah I'm sure red corner
faces the whole time no I probably
doesn't I feel like it would start to
feel bad cuz you know you'd be sitting
there like you'd beef and I'd be crying
like rip his arms off that's how [ __ ]
strong we are when we're scared yeah
like really think you can break walls
like a long great finger purple and I
got a shot one time yeah I love sitting
here thank you guys for watching our
asses
so please enjoy them as much as we do
woah dude I am really nervous being next
to both you this is crazy
yeah whoever recommended that forgot it
was you're on our Facebook the other day
thank you yeah thank you that does look
really cool it looks different it looks
like my Paranormal Activity the market
works Ben yeah try to do that cross
between Chronicle and Paranormal
Activity in a way yeah that's pretty
cool and they made an Asian guy the lead
hell yeah
you don't see that anymore in stereotype
breaking stereotypes [ __ ]
thank you fetched a fresh wow there's
sweat dribbling on the back of my neck
right now do I see it alright guys love
your new to the channel subscribe so you
can see more hot babes like this
sometimes just me though which is
suitable bc we go get a drink ladies huh
i want to donate yeah okay well it's
it's at a place where you like make your
doughnut
there's a place right that's what I said
in the car that's why I said like white
let's go like and when he's like you
guys want to hang out tonight we're
going it exists yeah we're in joking
that could be dangerous
okay doughnuts have holes in them ha ha
I'm not talking to put it through though
uh what I don't know no husband to me